Mighty Marvel may be dominating pop culture,
but not everyone is feeling the love.
In a recent conversation with Variety, Jennifer
Aniston star of the beloved sitcom Friends
and the upcoming Apple TV+ series The Morning
Show lamented what she saw as a dearth of
cinematic choices due to the popularity of
comic book movies.
It was a rather hard segue in an interview
which had, up until that point, been focused
on The Morning Show and how it had been shaped,
in part, by the "Me Too" movement.
Aniston was asked a simple question about
what prompted her return to television fifteen
years after shooting her last episode of Friends,
and in her response, she veered quickly from
marveling about all of the awesome choices
available to viewers since the advent of streaming
to… well, not marveling about Marvel.
She said,
"And then you're seeing what's available out
there, and it's just diminishing and diminishing
in terms of, it's big Marvel movies.
Or things that I'm not just asked to do […] [I'm
not] really that interested in living in [front
of] a green screen."
Well, we suppose it's kind of a bummer when
you're an actress who is well-known for starring
on one of the most popular sitcoms in the
history of television, and you then find that
your agent is always trying to talk you into
taking roles in these silly comic book pictures,
where you'll be forced to report to work and
pretend to talk to a gun-toting CGI raccoon
all day.
"Ha ha ha ha."
"That's a fake laugh."
"It's real!"
The interviewer responded to this unprompted
diss by noting how much Hollywood has changed
in recent years, to which Aniston replied,
"It's changed so much.
I think we would so love to have the era of
Meg Ryan come back.
I just think it would be nice to go into a
movie theater, sit cozy.
I think we should have a resurgence.
Let's get the Terms of Endearment back out
there.
You know, Heaven Can Wait, Young Frankenstein,
Blazing Saddles, Goodbye Girl."
It seems to have become somewhat fashionable
to trash the Marvel machine as of late, however
so, while it might seem a little out of left
field for Aniston to cite Marvel movies as
the reason why she's choosing to continue
working in television, she's certainly not
alone.
Most recently, Martin Scorsese made headlines
for blasting comic book movies in general,
and in far more direct fashion.
When asked if he had kept up with the latest
releases in the superhero genre, the filmmaker
flatly stated,
"That's not cinema.
Honestly, the closest I can think of them,
as well made as they are, with actors doing
the best they can under the circumstances,
is theme parks.
It isn't the cinema of human beings trying
to convey emotional, psychological experiences
to another human being."
Scorsese isn't the only acclaimed filmmaker
to make the dubious comparison between comic
book films and theme parks.
In a 2018 conversation with Radio Times magazine,
Jodie Foster unloaded on the entirety of the
superhero genre, going so far as to say that
such films pollute the cinematic landscape
in much the same way that poor environmental
practices pollute the planet.
Foster said,
"Going to the movies has become like a theme
park.
Studios making bad content in order to appeal
to the masses and shareholders is like fracking
you get the best return right now, but you
wreck the earth.
It's ruining the viewing habits of the American
population, and then ultimately, the rest
of the world."
The comic book movie backlash, while nothing
new, does appear to be picking up a little
steam.
Perhaps it has something to do with the fact
that Avengers: Endgame recently became the
highest-grossing film of all time, or that
the entire world briefly lost their minds
when Spider-Man was temporarily evicted from
the Marvel Cinematic Universe, or that Joker
has become the most talked-about film of the
fall.
We submit, however, that a sizable market
for non-comic book fare still exists, and
that if actors like Aniston and filmmakers
like Scorsese don't want to work in the genre,
nobody is going to force them to.
Heck, we hear that Scorsese just made his
best film in years.
It's called The Irishman, and it's not even
about a guy flying around in a green suit,
defeating his enemies by pelting them with
explosive shamrocks.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.